so i know this is going to come
as a big shock to a lot of you but
i i'm not cisgender
i'm also not straight
[Music]
glad i got that off my chest uh in all
seriousness though
this has kind of been on my mind
since the coming out video from abigail
thorne
who runs philosophy tube she came out in
a recent video titled
identity and 2021
has been a bit of a year of
coming out already for a number of
people other notable examples so far
this year
include james stephanie sterling who
came out as
non-binary and has begun hosting the gym
inquisition
in their non-binary finery and also
as a capper to a very heartfelt video
about his experience being raised
jehovah's witness
chris stuckman came out as pansexual
and there's a lot of
well first of all in all three cases i
support these creators i think they all
they came out in the way that was more
comfortable that was most comfortable
for each one of them and in all cases i
think it was lovely abigail came out in
a very
philosophical manner
uh stephanie came out very in your face
and boisterously
as is their want and chris uh almost
seemed a little hesitant but
since he was dealing with so much other
stuff in that video he decided to
rip off all the band-aids and he seemed
really relieved for having done so
now even though we've had a cluster of
these in the last few months it's not
exactly an
absolutely new phenomenon natalie wynn
over at contra points had developed a
decent following back when she was
presenting
more masculine or sort of gender
queer-ish and not
flat-out femme arguably the youtuber who
had the
largest following prior to coming out
was
eugene lee yang over at tri guys who
came out a couple years ago
in fabulous fashion to announce to the
world that he is gay
but i don't actually really want to talk
about
the coming outs themselves largely
because
it's not something you can really make
broad statements about
some people have spoken very eloquently
about some of the specific instances
jesse gender did a wonderful video
talking about the
impact and the influence of abigail's
coming out video
but you certainly can't make bold
statements because
coming out is a incredibly personal
experience it's very different
for everyone who has to do it so rather
than
try and lump them all together and i
think
kind of do a disservice to them i
instead want to talk about something
that
i have seen start to happen in terms of
the conversations
around creators who have come out
um and something that i think
some people it would be helpful for
you to hear a certain trap that some
people are falling into
so a bit like when i talked about
elliott page this is more about the way
in which we discuss
these creators than about the creators
themselves
now if you didn't see my video on
elliott page which i'd encourage you to
do i'm not going to be re
reiterating too many of those points but
just quick reminder
uh if somebody comes out as a new
name or pronoun preference and or
gender uh you need to refer to them as
such even when you were referring to
work that they did prior to coming out
or prior to
transition public visible transition
so when you talk about abigail and
philosophy tube
it's abigail it's she even if you're
talking about work
that she did years ago while in no way
presenting as feminine
so that's basic that's basic just to
reiterate that
but instead i want to talk about
something that i tend to see
which is fans well
possibly detractors as well but anyone
who's gonna knock on a
trans or lgbtq plus or whatever
person for coming out is an audience who
isn't going to listen to me in the first
place so i'm not really going to deal
with them
but i have seen fans and people
in more or less good faith start to
become speculative
in terms of doing things like
going back through old videos looking
for early indicators
looking for signs and
starting to try and construct a timeline
of transition or gender identity or
sexuality acceptance and while i'm going
to talk about this through the lens of
lgbtq
and queer identities and coming out as
such
what i'm going to say actually applies
to basically any time
any creator brings to the attention of
the public something about themselves
that was not known and is in
contradiction to what the assumptions
might have been about them
so as another example if a creator
comes out and begins to talk about
having depression
or anxiety or any number of uh
conditions that affect their day-to-day
lives adhd for the record
um anything like that this sort of same
thing does apply where people will
try and look for signs
and or discuss new meaning
behind things that they did previously
and to a certain extent this is just
going to happen it's not something you
can help
so if for whatever reason you find
yourself looking
at an earlier work before these creators
came
out publicly and you happen to know like
if you're
not scouring it looking for things but
if you're just watching because
maybe it's one you haven't seen before
maybe you felt the need to refresh
yourself on it
your brain is going to start to look for
patterns because that's what human
brains do
that's fine you can't help that i can't
help that
but what you can help and what you need
to be careful of and watch out for
is don't start to take that
attempt for you from your brain to
recognize patterns
don't then make the mistake of trying to
build a narrative of somebody else's
life
absent their input
or consent so there
are some creators out there who have
been
open about the timeline of their own
life and journey of self-discovery heck
i wrote a freaking book about mine
so some of us are fairly public and i
for one have always been pretty open
about answering questions about it
but if they are not like that
if a creator doesn't give you specifics
doesn't give you a timeline doesn't
break it all down for you it's
very invasive to try and do so
anyway to bring up abigail again for a
moment
in her video she the only
frame of time that she gives is one year
and that is the
length of time that she says she has
been out to the people closest to her
in her day-to-day life that gives no
indication
of what her journey was like prior to
that or how long it took
or how many steps there were how long
was the questioning period any number of
things and it's
rude and invasive to try and
assemble that information because if
they wanted you to know
creators would tell you look to a
certain extent
anyone who makes their living on this
platform or anything
vaguely similar to it we are in the
public eye
and we have chosen to make parts of
ourselves
our lives our thoughts our
minds are being public
and visible but
we still have the right to decide what
is going to be public what is going to
be visible
and if we choose not to discuss
something
the best thing that you can do is try
and respect that
and i know some people won't and i know
some people will say well
if you're in the public eye you have no
right to privacy
yeah we do and it's especially
troubling for me when i see people who
believe themselves to be allies and
think that in some way they're
helping or being supportive by going
back and looking for the signs
and like my own inclinations for the
most part is to
not speculate on a creator's personal
life
by and large i mean there's a reason
that i have almost never
in the many years of this channel talked
about a creator's
personal life generally i almost
exclusively talk about their work and
the few times that i
have broadening conversations about
an artist or creator's personal life
i'm honestly kind of terrified to go
back and look at those videos because i
think i
might end up feeling ashamed of them
and part of the reason for my at this
point
increased awareness of this even though
it was something that like i
thought it was pretty good about is i've
made this mistake
there was a point some time ago
when a creator whose work i enjoyed and
still enjoy
i thought that i saw
indications in their videos that
maybe they were like
me little things and
again i'm not going to say any of what
they were
but little things felt familiar
to me little things that were said
little things that were done
made me think i think i know what
they're going through
and then to my
shame and hubris
i reached out to them
basically saying
i think you might be going through
something like this
i've gone through something like this if
you're needing someone to talk to
i'm here and i had no business
doing that i had no right
to speculate about somebody else's
life somebody i didn't know
it was kind of the first time in a while
that i got a reminder
of the fact that i am not immune to
parasocial relationships
the one-sided relationship where you
feel like you know
the person on the screen but they don't
know you
and it was made clear to me that
what i did was invasive
was a violation of their privacy even
though i didn't like i didn't try and
look up stuff i didn't dig through stuff
it was taking in the work that they put
out there but i
still overstepped i'm grateful that i
didn't do so publicly
you know there's no there's no twitter
footprint for this i didn't make a video
about this but i
did still do it
and it was wrong
and having seen
again people who are fans and supportive
start to venture down that road
of
piecing together somebody else's life
story
it begins with oh i want to better
understand them let's look at their old
stuff
oh look at this maybe that was a sign
maybe that was an indicator
and it ends with watching completely
different people
and seeing those people do something and
then leaping to a conclusion of oh
well this other creator did things like
that and
now they've come out as whatever they've
come out as
maybe this other creator who i'm seeing
do these early things
maybe that mean and then suddenly you
are
not only trying to backfill the first
creator's life you are trying to project
forward
a timeline of the life of somebody you
don't
know i have
felt so much joy in my heart in 2021
for abigail for stephanie
for chris and previously for all the
other creators that i've seen come out
before that
but i don't know them i don't know any
of them
and neither do you
and trying to assemble a picture of
their life
that they haven't made public trying to
get a view into their world the kind of
view that they reserve
for their true friends who know them
you have no right it is invasive
it is not supportive and
it's a frighteningly easy thing to slip
into doing
i did i learned from it
so there's that i'll take it
i've seen in too many spaces in too many
areas
people start to head down that same road
it's not good for you to start to think
you know
someone to a level of intimacy that you
don't and can't
and it's not good for them
to have people doing that especially if
they're doing that
in any kind of social forum on twitter
on discords in youtube channels
and again some people will do it in bad
faith
but if you're happy
for someone who's come out
then just take in the information
they are prepared to provide you
please don't speculate about what they
might not be saying
or what dots they haven't connected
if they wanted them connected they would
do it i'm sorry that this was kind of a
down note video especially on a topic
that again
brings me a lot of joy
i feel so wonderful
seeing people with platforms
the size of abigail and chris
and james stephanie sterling the gender
mess
their term i'm allowed to say it
but
and obviously i had my coming out
experiences but
i had it at 10 000 subscribers
they're doing it at hundreds of
thousands
million subscribers
they're doing this the visibility
warms me
and i hope it does you
but don't try and cash that warmth in
to attain something that isn't for you
isn't meant for you they'll give you
what they want you to have
so there we go
sort of how we talk about and process
people who come out and again applicable
to much more than just lgbtq plus
uh people but that's that's my
experience so that's how i'm gonna talk
about it
thank you very much for listening thank
you for your time
and your support this video is made
possible by my
patrons if you wish to support what i do
there's the thing
there are rewards for every tear and all
that sort of thing
i also have merch links other social
medias are down in the description
but you don't have to do any of it
because at the end of the day you are
the council and i'm only running the
meetings
and just remember even if you make
mistakes
like i did you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
this council is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
um
[Music]
you